[Music]
john is in atlanta georgia
hey john welcome to the ramsay show
how you doing today dave better than i
deserve sir what's up in your world
dave uh where it is uh i work for my
father
and uh we're in the construction
business um
pretty large company we've got 40
employees um
about seven million top line uh
gross but anyways i'm 29 years old i've
been working with them for 10 years now
and i'm working around 60 to 65 hours a
week
and i'm wondering
uh i've talked to him about scaling back
uh my hours but he
you know continues to emphasize you know
you need to put your time in you need to
work and
financially i have all my ducks in a row
like you teach um
you know i've got emergency funds uh
well and uh well more than what you
teach
and uh out of debt and i'm just kind of
wondering am i wrong or want to
uh drop my hours back because i have a
wife and two kids
and um just kind of want to know your
thoughts
on that yeah the only time i work that
amount of hours are ask somebody to work
that amount of hours is for a
sprint a short season to knock something
out now the short season could be
for a year uh it could even be for two
years but it's you know
while we're trying to get something up
and moving or there's an emergency
uh and it falls under the heading of uh
you know country sayings but
you know make hay while the sun shines
right and so if you got to put in 16
hour days get the hay out of the field
before the rain kills it
uh and kills your dadgum crop you got to
go do that shut up
you know and if you uh and the other one
is get the ox out of the ditch meaning
that there's
something's broken right it's something
and we got to get the
you know we got to get that item fixed
so if the servers go down around here my
guys here are here two in the morning
but they're not here at two in the
morning every week it's because
something broke
right yeah and i'm not here because i
can't even spell servers so it wouldn't
do any good for me to be here unless i
hand in somebody some coffee but
but you know so the question is is this
a way of life
or is this the fact that we're in the
middle of a construction boom and you
guys need to get the hay out of the
field
well it's a way of life i mean we've
been doing it like i said
it's uh you know and he's worked he's
worked 60 70 hours his whole life
and that's just what he does well i like
hard-working people okay as opposed to
lazy people
they're handy to have around but when
i'm coaching small business people if i
was coaching you're all small business
based on what you just told me i would
say you have a breakdown
in staffing whatever it is you are doing
with that 60 hours you need to hire
somebody to do part of it
if all of that time is spent in
leadership that means you guys don't
have enough leadership in the
organization
you need to put some supers in there and
have some money come out of your pocket
so you get a quality of life back
if you're in there swinging a hammer
then you need to get somebody else in
there swinging a hammer part of the time
or whatever it is
that you could get your life back
because you know when i started this
thing
i mean sharon ramsey will tell you she
was a single mom for two years
freaking 16 hour days man i mean i was
busting it but that was for 18 to 24
months to get the airplane off the
ground
but once it's in the air you can
throttle back it doesn't take as much
fuel to keep it flying as it does to get
it off the ground
and so that's that's the distinction i
make
and but if your dad is signing you up
for 30 more years of workaholism
i'll pass yeah
well i sure i sure appreciate dave uh
just been stuck on the fence and just
trying to
kind of just get some you know i trust
your opinion well
here's the thing he's not as good
at his job when he's working 60 hours a
week year in and year out
because you're freaking tired your brain
doesn't work as good
and so you're not as good a leader
you're not as good an estimator
you're not as good at whatever it is
you're doing during that time
because you're tired i mean you can do
it for a sprint
but you can't do this over an extended
period of time and get the maximum use
out of the business it's a bad business
decision
but i mean i i understand i grew up in a
household where the answer to
everything's work
you know shut up and go to work you know
so i get it i get the i
and i'm kind of that way wired inside
but i've had to learn
to be a little bit more sophisticated
business owner and say
if i have a team that's working 60 hours
that means i've understaffed the area
yeah and and and i'll get better
efficiency and better quality results
out
if i'll properly staff it's kind of like
you know
never taking off on sunday take off on
sunday god said rest today you know why
because your productivity goes up
dramatically in the other six days
if you rest a day if you bust all the
way through seven days you don't get the
productivity studies tell us you don't
get it the results
and it's the same thing here so i would
make the case to your dad if i were you
now we need to rethink this this is what
got us here
and i honor you for your hard work all
these years you built this with the
sweat of your brow and the calluses on
your hand and i love you
and i honor you and i respect you but
we're our business has grown to a point
we need to reach a better level of
sophistication where we can have a life
and oh by the way we can't attract
good quality people if we work them like
donkeys
if we send them into the salt mines and
don't let them out you know nobody wants
to work for us
because of this and so that that's
you know i think you can make the case
to him but if he absolutely just says no
i own it shut up you're gonna do what i
say
then dude i guess you're gonna have to
hit the eject button but that'll be real
painful for him and you
because his dream is for you to work
with him and it's a joy to work with
your son
when you can or your daughter when you
can i have the joy of doing both
and but uh you know there's no question
you have to you have to look
at this through some some good strong
eyes good question man we appreciate you
joining us
not something i usually have to coach
someone on less work
you should have to coach them on more
work you know
it's oh
man open phones at triple eight eight
two
five five two two five
the bible says i've been young and i've
been old
but i've never seen the righteous or
their seed
breaking bread also says the diligent
prosper
diligence is excellence in the ordinary
over time
diligent people prosper i've been young
and i've been old but i've never seen
the righteous or their seed their ch
their kids begging bread you just don't
want to
read proverbs unless you understand work
ethic
because the bible's really clear that
work is where money comes from and it's
also where dignity comes from
the fact that you throw your shoulders
back and move some stuff around out in
the marketplace
builds your self-confidence it builds
your personal
value the tipping point is when
you're doing it 80 hours a week since
why we don't have any trouble hiring
developers we
can never get enough of them because
we're growing so fast but we get
these ruby on rails guys and these
platform architecture guys because we
work
40 hours a week in the tech world
they all work 80 hours a week they work
those guys into the dead gum dirt
and they come to work here and they get
to do work that matters and they're here
40 hours a week so we're a
highly attractive position for people in
the tech world
by the way just check we're hiring at
davram ramseysolutions.com
check it out